-And finally, I just heard about
a new survey that said,
"Over 53% of all Americans
are big Taylor Swift fans."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, apparently, the music
industry is putting out
this kind of data
all the time.
So I thought we'd take
a look at some of it now.
It's time for "Tonight Show"
Pie Charts.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just look at some of these.
First up, when asked...
Interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's another one now.
When asked...
[ Applause and laughter ]
Up next, when asked...
[ Cheers and applause ]
D4vd JVKE...
-I.
-Exclamation point.
-Yeah.
[ Audience laughs ]
-Next up, when asked...
-Oh.
-Interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next, when asked...
Where he hears that new music.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sock hop?
-♪ Let's go to the hop ♪
-♪ Oh-bah-bah-bah ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ Bah-bah-bah ♪
-♪ Let's go to the hop ♪
Up next, when asked...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As coworker Denise ]
I'mma do it one more time.
I can do it better.
[ Normal ] When asked...
There you have it.